and who died welcome to divided thank
you for being with us
you know right er you know a comedian
would also be fair to say you're
something of a provocateur these days
well a provocateur would imply that I'm
deliberately trying to upset people or
annoying people which is never my
intention at all it just so happens that
some of the opinions I've come out with
tend to provoke and I'm not sure why
that is but it isn't deliberate I'm just
saying what I think so if the intention
is is not necessarily to to provoke what
is the intention of your work I think it
comes down to the distinction between
comedy and satire you know I I'm really
fond of wh Jordans view of satire which
is that it's essentially angry but
optimistic because it believes it can
change the world right it believes that
there's something wrong with the current
system and it pokes at it in in order to
change whereas comedy is is is more kind
of just resigned it's pessimistic as its
resigned that we live in this absurd or
for worse we may as well just laugh at
it but you would be happy if things
changed as a result of what you do of
course but I'm not delusional enough to
think I've got that kind of clout who
might have that sort of clout someone
perhaps like to Tanya McGrath I mean
this is your latest creation from for
those who haven't spent any time on
social media recently and don't know who
she is tell me a little bit about her
yeah but we've got to remind myself that
a lot of people are not on Twitter
she's what you'd call a kind of fourth
wave feminist which is an intersectional
feminist and that's the form of feminism
which likes to take into account every
aspect of one's oppression so your race
gender sexuality all that kind of thing
and it sort of maps it on a kind of I
suppose a kind of chart of oppression
that's the way intersectionality works
she's the kind of recognizable figure
the kind of very po-faced humorless
judgmental very posh you know she lives
in Kensington she's got another house in
the Cotswolds daddy pays for everything
you know but she she's determined to
expect to tell the world how oppressed
she is she loves that she loves writing
about her victimhood status you know
with no self-awareness at all it's it's
specifically not a parody of someone
because I didn't want to do that I
wanted to be a certain type of person
but I read a lot of the the books by I
suppose what you would say left-leaning
commentators and colonists who fit this
category I wouldn't like to name them as
a bit mean I think
but but I think we all know who I'm
talking about and and it's people who
write books about a millionaire as
independently wealthy people who were
privately educated had everything handed
on a play and they write books about
what victims they are and to me that's
just funny I just think that's really
funny and it's worth it's worth holding
a mirror up to that you know that's all
I'm doing there
so much of that of the character
character of titania revolves around
that the concept of being walk again for
those who have not gained any amount of
time in this world what does it mean
because some wear that as a badge of a
badge of honor some are actually
accepted as a definition of themselves
it's odd I mean woke has started to be
used and ironically now more and more
whereas for a while there it wasn't the
idea of being woke is being very aware
of social justice years issues very
aware of inclusivity diversity the idea
of being very sensitive to people's
feelings and not offending anyone so all
of this is obviously good it's a well
intentioned thing this is social justice
should be something that we're all
celebrating but the problem is is the
way in which it's been done by this very
small minority of people who have taken
it a step too far I suppose in what way
that they're all released and sorry is
that they leap to conclusions well
there's a number of things they're
impervious to debate so they're not
they're not up for debating any issues
their way is the right way they've got
this incredible narcissistic certainty
that they never doubt themselves you
know which I find funny I found that
really funny but also a little bit
dangerous there they want to police
speech they want to stop you saying
certain words they believe in this
utopian world where if only they could
control the way people speak and the way
people think they could solve all of the
world's problems it's completely
delusional you must have noticed so
there's a there's a certain type of
person to some contingent people I don't
predict for a second out that they think
that they're doing the right thing that
the woke ideology they think is a good
purifying thing but that's the problem
with a cult and it is a kind of cult is
that they don't see the damage they're
doing in the end and the harm they're
creating well let's take a look at some
of the work of miss McGrath it's never
okay for men to give CPR to an
unconscious woman resuscitation is just
a fancy word for rape now I'm not the
most clued up on all of these issues but
you're gonna have to take me through I
think a number of steps how to tell me
what is being satirized here okay fine
so that is a tweet that was a response
to a particular article and what it is
it is they about the idea that is kind
of intrinsic in fourth wave feminism now
it's going back to this all sort of
Victorian view of men as essentially
rapacious sort of violent beings and and
women is he sort of sort of damsels in
distress they can think to you know
things like rape culture yeah exactly
exactly said the rape culture idea for
instance it is predicated on this notion
that we live in a culture that
normalized normalizes or approves of
rape which isn't true you know we live
in a culture where we're actually know a
civilized person approves of rape and
and and so therefore I wanted to address
that know obviously I'm aware that this
is a sensitive issue she goes into those
areas because she's got that certainty
about herself and she doesn't mind
saying these things that seem outrageous
to us and of course nobody says what she
just said that is a huge exaggeration
and what I'm often doing is taking an
absurd idea which is real in the real
world and taking it to its extremes
because that's how it's funny if I if I
just simply replicate it exactly what
was being said then it probably wouldn't
work as well do you think do you think
people get the joke in that sense though
do you think do you think that the women
who speak in those terms but not to that
extent understood what you were trying
to do there or do you think they thought
you're just having a pot barn but who am
I having a pop out though that that's
interesting who's the victim in that
joke really because it's not mocking
rape victims by any means I just
wouldn't do that it's talking about the
heightened sensitivities that we now
have about relations between men and
women to the extent that somebody might
be reticent to even save someone's life
because of the notion of consent that
because because the notion has been so
sort of misinterpreted in the discourse
so that's that's the the target it
certainly isn't someone who's been the
victim of sexual assault but let's have
a look at another of tutor Nia's tweets
and this this this deals with the white
Saviour story that has come up recently
of course with Stacey Dooley taking a
trip for four for comic relief at next
month I'll be tuning the deprived areas
of Africa to teach poor black people
about intersectionality and the problem
with white saviors I mean didn't David
Lammy have a bit of a point yeah came to
Stacey Dooley I mean David Lammy the the
point which I think with him where I
think he did have a point was probably
that he's talking about the idea that
countries that are I suppose
the poorer countries that developed the
developing countries should be
encouraged to I suppose fend for
themselves be able to build up their own
economy look after themselves okay but
where I feel he went wrong is he saw
that he could only see it through the
prism of skin color what he was really
attacking was was Stasi Dooley's skin
color he was saying it's bad optics
that's what he was saying is he's saying
is not good for a white face to be seen
amongst a group of poor black gme of the
argument for looking just a little bit
colonial I don't this white rich for
this rich white person comes to Africa
and says I'm here to help
do you really think her intention was
colonial I mean surely no it's nothing
to do with in turn just as I think it's
I think it's everything to do with
intent but that's why I'm criticizing
because I think the OP that's not enough
I mean also is David Lammy really in a
position to speak on behalf of poor
Ugandan sore or anyone you know is he
just because of the color of his skin
well you may be you're essentially
arguing there that the only people who
could speak on behalf of / yu gardens
are pure Ugandan that's exactly what I'm
arguing yeah I think I think someone who
is starving and destitute isn't going to
turn away someone with some food if
they've got a white face they don't care
about this stuff and you might say that
well going out there and charity and aid
work it's not really doing something in
the broad term it's helping those
individual people it's a good thing and
actually I think intentions really
important them it Stacy Julie giving up
her time lending her profile to
something that is a good cause is it
really helpful to be criticizing
charities and people who do these really
good things and again with Lambie
I'm sure the intention is good right
I've no doubt I don't think he's doing
anything malevolent in any way but the
there there you have the problem because
you generate a lot of resentment about
something which is you know actually a
good thing since satire always meant to
punch up yeah it strikes me that that a
lot of the time her targets are you know
marginalized groups but that's not the
case I mean I think you you're entitled
to that misinterpretation but I don't
think she is punching down it's not the
vulnerable groups it's not gay people or
after it it's the exactly it's the
paternalistic very privileged people who
are saying I will speak on behalf of all
of these people and I'm you know that
that's the the target but also I mean I
never I'm I think the comedy you can
punch down you can bunch or in all sorts
of directions right because that's the
nature of humor it sometimes cruelty can
be funny
when I'm writing comedy or satire I
don't punch down I think when I'm
attacking whoa culture I'm very much
punching up and the reason I say that is
because it is first art it's a very
small minority of people but they're
very vocal very powerful and it infects
everything it affects television the
media journalism I want to explore that
a little bit further in just a second
but another another cancer that you were
involved in the creation of Jonathan pie
they did the the newsmen that many News
men wish they could they could be on
occasion I just want to take a look at a
clip and this is all to do with that
that that case in Scotland count dank
Euler an online poster who taught his
dog to do a Nazi salute let's just take
a quick look it's a cute little pug dog
reacting to the one of the worst things
you could ever say that's the point it's
a joke yes
where are the artists the writers where
are the where are the comedian's where
are they why they not helping in arms
you've got you got Ricky Gervais David
Patil a handful of others that's it
basically everyone else is a coward of
course it's a character of course as an
exaggeration but but contained therein
I'm assuming quite a lot of your own
personal views about the countdown
killer pug case in that case absolutely
there's a lot of things I've written for
Jonathan pipe which I don't necessarily
foot of course agree with because he's a
character who isn't me I think it's fair
to say I think your point is fair that
in that case yes I would say that I I
broadly speaking agree with what the
characters saying I mean there are a lot
of people who appoint the fighters as
Jonathan pine did that actually the
people who seem to be claiming the high
ground the moral high ground on the
absolutist free speech argument are
figures from the right and in fact the
far right really yeah it's I mean it's a
real it's a real problematic does that
concern you does that not what means you
think twice about whether or not you are
connecting your approach that you're you
are essentially being allied with Tony
Robinson on this issue what concerns me
is that the far right is steadily rising
that concerns me I mean we I mean four
of the of the last 18 terror plots have
been foiled by the intelligence services
have come from the far right so it's
something it's still very much fringe
it's still a very small minority but
they are growing in in in and I think
largely that's because of the kind
of conditions we are creating and I
think identity politics is at the heart
of this because if you think about the
way identities of politics work the far
right is an identity in movement the far
left similarly they have a lot in common
because they just see people through the
lens of race gender sexuality that
neither agree with free speech not
really I mean the far right is no friend
of free speech right and I think it's a
really bad situation that we've
developed where we are enabling the far
right to hold on to the free speech
mantle to say we're the ones who are
defending free speech
well they don't believe in free speech
there wasn't an overwhelming outpouring
of support from the community community
no and I understand that because of the
I suppose because Tommy Robinson had
been so vocal in his defense of count
dangler but therein lies the problem
doesn't it Tommy Robinson organized the
day for freedom which was a sense of
their free speech rally in London and of
course as a result of that you didn't
have many there was some but you did
have many left-wing activists attending
that that march because it becomes
tribal because all of a sudden people
associate free speech with the far-right
that's in really a terrible situation to
be in and we need more people from all
sides of the political spectrum to stand
up for them for the notion of free
speech as the left-wing lost its sense
of humor there's this assumption isn't
there that that jokes and comedy and
poking fun can have a kind of damaging
societal effect I think when you look at
the what we would call the woke comedy
movement which is now pretty much
establishment that is the establishment
now their belief is that comedy needs to
be more responsible I think there's
something very patronizing in this
approach because it entails two core
beliefs that I just don't hold any truck
with the first is that minority groups
in an audience need to be protected we
need to protect them from hearing jokes
that could relate to their particular
circumstances now I don't want to sit in
an audience and be told that I can't
hear a joke about gay people because it
might upset me I don't wanna be patched
noise like that so that's the first
thing and the second thing is this
belief that basically the masses aren't
there to be entertained there to be
educated you know and it's the
comedian's responsibility to to say
jokes that are not ambiguous in any way
that can't be misinterpreted well why
why do you have such a degraded view of
humanity that you think people don't get
a joke they do that virtually everyone
understands the difference in a joke in
real life so I think if somebody takes
offense because of something I've said
and I did not intend to offend them
that's their problem but
that's called life right there's
literally nothing I could talk about
that won't offend somebody at some point
but if I deliberately go out my way and
I think I'm gonna I'm gonna upset that
person or I'm gonna upset that group and
and I'll do a joke that just that isn't
particularly but just goes after them I
couldn't like my conscience wouldn't
allow me to do that my intent is clear
and but also we live in a world where
people will misinterpret what you say no
matter what you say and that's just part
of being a human being I guess what do
we lose if we lose this that the access
to the freedom of speech that you aspire
it's the fundamental bedrock of a
civilized society is that people can say
whatever they whatever they want and
think whatever they want to think
without the state trying to prevent them
from doing so I understand why people
say certain forms of speech should be
off-limits because because as I say it's
well-intentioned but there is this
belief in this this utopian belief that
if we just get people to say the right
words everything will be fixed
it won't Humanity is a messy business
and the price you pay for freedom is
some awful people are going to say some
awful things and the best way to deal
with that is to mock those people to
argue against those people to stand up
and say no you're wrong and this is why